[Music]
hello and welcome to Google i/o 2017
I'm Patrick Brady from the Android team
at Google and I'm here with AJ and Chen
to give you guys an update on Android
and cars we have a lot to cover today
and I see there's still people streaming
in
but let's buckle up and get driving the
automotive industry is really heating up
I think that's no secret we see cars
rapidly transforming from disconnected
mechanical machines to powerful
connected computers on wheels
the controls are shifting from
mechanical knobs and dials to software
defined interfaces accessible through
touch screens and voice controls cars
are getting more sensors and screens
microphones connectivity and compute
power we also see a convergence between
the mobile and automotive worlds
creating exciting opportunities to
revolutionize the way we interact with
our cars today through open platforms
artificial intelligence and vibrant
developer ecosystems Android auto is an
effort from Google and our partners to
bring all of these advances together and
create a safe and seamless experience
for drivers everywhere it's still early
days but today anyone with an Android
auto compatible car can see the
beginnings of this vision at work with
access to their favorite Android apps
right from the cars display we continue
to expand the number of Android auto
compatible models available through
great partnerships with over 50 car
brands there are over 300 Android auto
cars convey label today compatible cars
available today including first launches
from Chrysler Renault Volvo in the last
few months alone and that's triple the
number from just one year ago it's well
on its way to becoming a standard
feature in every new car but of course
we know that not everyone has a new car
and so we've also made the Android auto
app available as a standalone experience
on Android phones this opens up the
platform and ecosystem to many millions
of drivers no matter what kind of car
they drive whether you're looking to
stay connected with whatsapp Facebook
Messenger or a low or pass the time with
NPR one in audio books moddable or the
latest album release on Spotify the apps
drivers want on the road are available
through Android auto and before anyone
asks Waze is now hitting beta so we're
very excited to welcome them into
Android auto as well we're seeing strong
growth on the developer front as well in
fact we've seen a 50% increase in Auto
enabled apps in the Play Store since
last year but none of this would matter
if we didn't have users right well I'm
happy to say that Android auto usage is
growing like crazy as well here's where
we were at Google i/o 2016 and here's
where we are today at i/o 2017 we've
seen a 10x growth in usage over the last
year alone and the strong trajectory
continues but this is really just the
beginning and we're really more excited
about where Android is going on the road
ahead last year at i/o we announced that
we're building automotive features right
into the Android platform to make it a
turnkey solution for cars every bit as
much an automotive platform as it is a
mobile platform today we're doing this
because we believe open platforms are
powerful enablers of ecosystems they
reduce the cost of development and they
speed time to market in a sense they
accelerate innovation we're also doing
this because it enables us to deliver an
even more seamless driving experience
with all the information controls and
connectivity available through a single
system that's infused with the drivers
identity their digital life and
next we listen and learn from partners
who had already brought Android into
automotive and we worked hard to solve
the challenges they hit along the way a
robust and full-featured Bluetooth stack
a standard way to connect with the cabin
controls for windows and air
conditioning and car sensors a system
that boots instantly at Google i/o 2016
we showed this all off with Android
nougat powering the entire in-car
experience of a concept Maserati the
windows the doors the air conditioning
the instrument cluster and as much as we
really loved that Maserati and I'd
really like to take it home it was a
concept and I think what we want what we
think you all want is to see real cars
running modern Android powered systems
the traction we're seeing in the
industry is pretty amazing just a few
short months after the official Android
new get release several of our partners
were demoing Android powered
infotainment systems at CES 2017
including Fiat Chrysler's Android
powered UConnect system earlier this
week the automotive industry heavyweight
with a reputation for building some of
the most advanced systems on the market
od announced that they will build their
next-generation infotainment systems on
Android please join me in welcoming
Alphonse faller head of connected car
and infotainment at Audi AG
[Applause]
[Music]
Patrick and our friends on Google thank
you very very much for being here that
we have got the invitation to be at the
Google i/o for Audi is the third time
that we are here at i/o and for Audi the
Google i/o is really really a special
event a great event we have a very very
long term relationship with Google and
together portray computing we have been
able to launch a lot of really cool
services over the last years we started
with Google Earth amazing Sirach view i3
few a lot of things and now and now the
really big next step is coming if you
are looking on the picture on this
picture we see as a brand-new Audi
internal design this design is based on
the best-in-class digital cockpit
technology and we see here three
absolute absolute automotive high-end
displays in the front and additional
displays in turn seven in the form based
on this digital cockpit we are able to
bring it in a really really amazing
design and and really straightforward
excellent user experience and in this
internal design we are doing a seamless
integration of embedded and through it
and I think that is really really a big
step if I'm to a short summary in terms
of time
what's ongoing automotives we are
bringing together this our
silicon-silicon partners really really
high-end computing inside the car next
step is with our friends from mobile
communication we are connecting all
costs all cars with high-speed LTE and
very soon also the safety to the whole
cloud ecosystem and now the point is
these are embedded Android we are able
to provide an open platform for
automotive and this enables us to invite
you to invite all of you to participate
in automotive development and such great
so thanks very much and looking forward
to see this concept on our show car
outside and have one or other for
discussion thank you very much thank
thank you Alphonse we couldn't be more
excited to partner with Audi again to
bring Android into their future cars but
you can't build an ecosystem with just
one partnership right and that's why I'm
happy to say that one of the industry's
most innovative companies Volvo is also
putting their weight behind the Android
in-car ecosystem I'm happy to welcome up
Henrik green senior vice president of
research and development at Volvo car
group to tell you a bit about their new
system
good afternoon and thank you the friends
at Google for inviting us here to this
great event thank you for the Sun and
most of all thank you for the sunscreen
I haven't dead looked at the mirror yes
so I'm not sure but I'm definitely
burned on the right side I mean we have
worked with Google for a number of years
on a different size of projects and of
course the recent Android also is a
fantastic success order but today we're
here to announce that our partnership is
going to the next level we are together
with Google team here going to develop
the next generation of connected car
infotainment and as always for Volvo
it's very important for us to create a
completely seamless solution where the
user experience is at the heart of
everybody and that we can provide a
better life and a better experience
through the integrated use of this
infotainment system now the design of au
existing place of course an enormous
important role but at the heart of it is
the operating system and here we
strongly believe that together with
Google we will develop the next
generation based on the Android platform
so again it's to you out there you are
the developers you are now the people
and the brainpower that will bring this
experience to life in the future course
so be with us here and show that we can
make the best connected infotainment
system and core experience out there
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
it's pretty cool right I definitely I
definitely encourage you to go check out
the demos that Audi and Volvo are
showing in the Android and iOS Evo's out
there as good as the cars look up on the
screens they look even better in person
sadly I have to say we're not giving out
any free cars this year at i/o so you
have to make do with a t-shirt but
outtie an outie involve our really true
pioneers in automotive electronics and
infotainment and we couldn't have picked
better partners to usher in the future
of connected cars we're really really
excited about that with the Android Auto
app on phones with 300 Android auto
compatible car models and with Android
built in systems hitting the road soon
we're pushing forward to revolutionize
the way we stay connected in our cars
creating a safe and seamless connected
experience for drivers everywhere but a
big part of the develop the drivers
digital life as Henrik and Alphonse said
is the applications and services they
use throughout their digital life on
their other devices and we need to bring
the ecosystem along for the ride so I'd
like to welcome up on stage AJ can Bembe
from the Android auto UX team to talk
about what this all means for developers
Thanks thank you budget
Thank You Patrick and I everyone my name
is AJ and I am the lead designer for
Android in-car infotainment Patrick
already detailed are we been out at work
to make Android the best possible
infotainment platform with improvements
to Bluetooth boot time car control such
as HVAC radio cast and source closers
and so on but Android is not only a
great platform it's also an entire
ecosystem of apps and services but first
I would like to talk about why are we
doing this so this is natural photo for
our field research and this driver is
trying to catch pokemon on Pokemon go
while at the wheel
and you can see the family crossing in
the background so don't worry everybody
safe and again this is not a stock image
and this is our researchers in the car
we see drivers out on the road and now
if this is happening with our
researchers in the vehicle the gist of
it is our internal research shows that
people drivers want to stay connected
and the memories of use their phone to
do so and that can link to situation
that are fundamentally unsafe we want to
observe a stay connected with you in
service of safe and predictable select
stupid three things here first
why is complex to design services for
the car what Android is going to help us
a platform then and finally what are the
various ways that you can integrate with
Android also as a developer
okay what is making designing apps and
services for the car as specific
exciting but are too sometimes
challenging Android is a platform point
infotainment across a wide range of
possible surfaces with shades aspect
ratio to be different densities
Fidelity's
the current tire is a meticulously
crafted experience everything is
optimized for safety of course but also
to provide a specific experience for
each brain and each price point this
place can be big small wide sole
interesting cluster or adds up displays
Android is a platform that support all
of these
but along with the output the inputs
methods are multiple as well search
crews are more and more common in the
course but also depart touchpad rotary
inputs and many more cut off that as
well and some systems or even average of
multiple input mechanism and Android is
a platform that support that as well
safety safety of courses in a variety we
are working really really hard to reduce
driver distraction visual distraction
manual distraction cognitive distraction
our internal user research team works
closely and iteratively with the broader
team to strengthen understanding of beam
vehicle and driver interaction and I
thought you get our future development
our team conduct the four national
research the studies the needs
assessment usability evaluation
quantitative surveys and formal driver
distraction testing as well they are
engaged in the positive working
relationship with external organizations
and they serve to date with the
regulation standards and we do all that
for partners and developers don't have
to do it so you can see the our driving
simulator is an expensive set up that
can obviously simulate driving
conditions we use it for many things
including the detection response task
that is one way that we use to evaluate
cognitive load we also use it for eye
tracking you can see on the picture KD
with the a purchase on your face and we
also use the oxygen glasses they are
little two that we use to simulate the
driver focusing on the road and glancing
a DUI they close on the open what I
would like to say is it's a complex and
expensive endeavor and again we are
doing all that our partners and drivers
don't have to worry too much about it
okay so now also what Android is doing
to app developers
so let me said earlier we know that
drivers want to stay connected and want
to have them with interfaces or safe and
predictable but the content the context
and the inner and 3 nature of modern
digital services can make that a
challenge the concept of in kind for 10
men used to be more predictable
now we've Android we are designing a
system that is ready to safely bring
into cars services that we know and use
on other platforms and as we like as
well
Android is already a great platform for
modern gentle services on phones on
tablets on TVs on wearables and now we
are bring that in cars as well the key
to adapt quickly and efficiently to the
wide diversity of women machine
interfaces that we find in industry is
modularity Android is abstracting away
this input and output so developers
don't have to worry about screen size or
shape or whether something is touch or
rotary we take care of that Android also
provides in an Enka platform so
developers can quickly to innovate and
focus on building innovative apps
without having to worry about all the
details one way Android does the heavy
lifting for developers is to template we
designed a system that enables
automotive-grade templates to safely and
relatively perform the most common
driving rate attacks those templates are
designed to a little wild variety of
regulatory concerns surprising for
Spotify don't start to worry about what
is the tap target size for some screens
or on many items can be displayed on one
screen in the given country or region we
take care of that and another way we
make anyway in recovery printable
experiences with apps agile powerful the
a bridge is not the most suitable
metaphor for the amount of automotive
space we've identified the key area for
the car and that it's easy to switch
between them and it's not only in our
own and also platform you can see this
today for a component in the
best-in-class systems designed by our
partners Rd and Volvo and be sure to
check their demos after in the IOT and a
droid and right outside here the most
commonly used function
are elevated so drivers can quickly and
safely switch between them without
having to make their way to an average
and we also want the experience to feel
personal and tailored we work hard to
make sure that Android understand when a
driver is in the car and can optimize
itself to safely bring the drivers up
and services
Android is already built in with
material support it's been a few years
now and we are fully leveraging this
framework in the vehicle to enable
frictionless personalization we want to
get to the point where a driver can step
into a rental car and have an extra that
is personalized and ready to drive now
to the last portion what are the
different ways that you can bring your
app of service into cars
Android is a common platform that
millions of directors already know how
to build for if you are already invested
in general and radical system we want to
make things easy for you Android as a
platform does the heavy lifting and
provide a set of tools and api's 2008
very easily with the car our goal is to
have one single platform across every
car let's look at that in more detail we
want to be respectful of the time and
resources the repair to commit to bring
the app and services to the car that's
why there are multiple ways you can
integrate with Android also depending on
the nature of your service of course and
for few of those apps it will require a
lot of more effort a lot more design
time and possibly more cost as well but
for most of the apps it would be less
effort and less time that would be
involved once we call full apps of
services that need full control of what
is displayed on the screen our last
example here in the great center of the
Volvo s90
that is on demo Google Maps is using
dynamics volleyball and pinchable maps
map tiles bringing a full app experience
necessitate a huge amount of Numan and
technical resources
you have to think about target size type
size then nice mode focus based system
such as water input on touchpad all of
this and required full testing
capabilities to ensure that the
resulting app is up to formal standards
regarding driver distraction Waze is
another example of an application that
their food pixel control and you can see
here presently in our Android also for
your car screen version not all the apps
on my application though for audio apps
we've created a set of templates that
safety offer all the misery
functionalities in a simple predictable
and safe manner here I would like to
exempt the example of the OD cuit spot
concept that is on demo as well
you can see our oddly elegantly
implemented the media station API the
developer can use to bring their big app
onto into house the templates are
working on all our surfaces screen
densities and inputs and there we go to
the state for driver distraction and the
great thing is all of the applications
that are already working with Android
auto for your phone screen or for your
car screen will be working here as well
without extra work from our developers
and you can also see all these really
really implemented Media Browser API and
here presented with pocket casts we can
find your content easily and safely in
as well at least immersive and write in
place in the car messaging is one of the
major use case in the car for SMS but
also advertise whatsapp or Facebook
Messenger or arrow the insulation with
photo is simple and based on Android
notifications all that is necessary is
to integrate with our external objects
with a policy voice centric messages
experience for your users this is
another example of the Media Browser
media stations implemented with appear
one but here you can see whatsapp
notification or or showing up
we've made them working great for safe
and profitable use on the phone that is
mounted on your dashboard of your car
and the great thing is that without it
work for whatsapp we can make it work on
different form factors here and relative
for your for your car screen and that is
working for touch but also focus based
systems such as rotary input another way
to integrate with photo is to the Google
assistant assistant with absent services
or inherently cross-platform and our
voice centric nature make them ideal is
rated for in-car use the next speaker is
going to talk more about that and so we
not explaining to two more details here
so that's what we are working hard on to
enable a healthy ecosystem in with
Android we work hard to abstract away
the complexity and provide developers
and car manufacturers little robust
up-to-date and secure platform now I'd
like to welcome Channel stage to talk
more about or you can liquid integrate
with the good assistant on Android auto
thank you then
Thank You AJ hello I'm Chen technical
lead and manager on the Google assistant
on Android auto team and I'm here to
tell you about how you the developers
can engage with users in the car see if
this scenario sounds familiar you're
running late for work can you rush out
the door on your drive you think back to
yourself that I actually lock the front
door wouldn't it be awesome if you could
talk to your car and say okay Google did
I lock the door or maybe on that same
commute you're thinking what meetings am
I actually rushing to or I better not
forget to buy milk before I go home it'd
be great if you could talk to your car
and say what's my next meeting or remind
me to buy milk before I go home these
are all things that the Google assistant
can help you with and more importantly
you as a developer can make your
services available via the assistant as
Adrienne mentioned before voice input is
critical in the car for safety reasons
we want to make sure the users keep
their eyes on the road and hands on the
wheel while the users are on this
journey we want to make sure the user
stays connected they can get things done
and stay entertained the Google
assistant can provide that intelligent
and conversational voice as we move from
a mobile first to an AI first world we
want it to be the ultimate copilot for
the user in the car users are spending
precious time in the car and we're
making the assistant help the user
complete the mission and make the
journey fun with the feature called my
days you can say okay Google tell me
about my day and the suspense will tell
you about upcoming calendar events
reminders commute traffic so you can hit
the ground running when you get to work
on the road your assistant can tell you
about traffic ahead or show you gas
stations if you need to make a pit stop
if you're bored you can ask the
assistant to play that favorite song
you've downloaded or listen to a variety
of music and podcasts we know that
staying connected is very important for
users on the road so we make calling and
messaging easy with voice actions like
call mom send a whatsapp message or read
my messages many of these experiences
are only possible because developers
like you has implemented the write API
so thanks you for helping us create that
great user experience since the
assistant is cross surface will help the
users get things done wherever they are
in the home and on the go Patrick and AJ
have already talked about how messaging
and media apps can integrate with
Android auto for a seamless and
consistent user experience in the car
those were the templated and
notification apps and a J's pyramid that
want to show a UI so there are tons of
other apps that don't fall under these
categories how can you as a developer
get your experience in the car without
having to deal with the complexity of
building a full automotive app and
having to accommodate different screen
sizes various inputs and outputs if your
service can be voiced centric in the car
and you want a lightweight integration
for reaching these users then the good
and Google assistant is a good option so
how do you build for the Google
assistant actions on Google is the
platform for developers to build for the
Google assistant the platform allow
developers to reach users wherever the
assistant is available
the platform uses cloud execution so
users don't need to pre install any app
when they ask for your service by name
you'll be connected immediately many
developers already building for the
actions on Google when building for
actions in Google there are three key
pieces that need to be defined by the
developer invocation triggers dialog and
fulfillment let me illustrate with an
example I like coding and I like fortune
cookies so I want to build a service
that gives me a daily dose of coding
fortune cookies so the first step is I
need to define my invocation trigger how
does the user connect to my service what
do they actually have to say in this
case I'll make it simple whenever the
user says talk to coding fortune cookie
then the Google assistant will connect
the user to my service the next step is
dialogues so once the user is connected
to my service how do I talk to them what
kind of information am i asking and what
kind of responses am I expecting i what
are valid responses what are invalid
responses in this case I'm going to make
you a simple question
do they want a Java or C++ fortune
cookie so there are only two valid
responses in this case so let's suppose
that the user picked Java now we can
move on to third third step which is
fulfillment for fulfillment I have all
the information that I need so how do I
go about committing that transaction
we're executing that action on behalf of
the user
so in this case I'm going to look in my
banks of Java fortunes and I'm going to
pick one out for today random one
today's fortune says Cody sure says for
true happiness prefer interfaces over
abstract classes
that's when I actually use everyday
that's a high level view of actions on
Google the Google assistant and actions
on Google are coming to Android auto and
will open up a wide possibility of these
cases agents and services are built on
top of the platform will transfer over
if you think that users will interact
with your agent or service in the car
it's a good idea to start thinking about
what is the user experience that you
want to build for that special context
one card specific consideration is
safety and driver distraction how can
you build a user experience that both
minimizes driver distraction and allow
users to get things done and stay
entertained let's think about some
potential use cases for engaging with
users in the car what is possible here
one idea is reservation it's a Friday
night and I'm meeting up with my husband
for dinner we pick out a restaurant and
on the way there I would love to be able
to say book a table and have that table
waiting for me by the time I get there
what would be even more awesome and
magical is the Google assistant and that
third-party service can suggest a good
reservation time that takes them to
account my location traffic and maybe
parking availability so I make a
reservation for a time I can definitely
make another ideas food ordering I'm
working late on a weeknight and I'm too
lazy to cook on my way home I would love
to be able to put in an order at my
favorite restaurant
and have that food delivered and arrived
at my home by the time I get there saves
on time saves on cooking like I
mentioned earlier how many times have
you driven away from your house and
can't remember whether you've actually
locked the front door be very cool if
you could say okay Google
my door or did I lock my door just lock
it
another one is life I'm driving home and
I actually hate walking into a dark
house because I'm actually afraid of the
dark it would be great if from the car I
could just say turn on my living room
light or turn on my dining room lights
and I never have to walk into a dark
house again games and entertainment how
many times have you and Ron long road
trips with kids where you struggle to
find a way to keep them entertained
would it be awesome if you could say
okay Google entertain my kids and have
games that are age-appropriate for
different kids so they can play whatever
they want they stay entertained and I
can focus on the road these are just
some ideas on ways developers can engage
with users in the car I look forward to
what creative ideas you come up with
please check out the actions on Google
site where they're actually code samples
and tools that help you build the
dialogue and triggers and fulfillment
steps so that makes it easier to bring
up your service we also have demos at
the IOT and Android domes will actually
be showcasing some of the use cases that
I just talked about including
controlling hue lights and auguste door
locks directly from inside the car thank
you and back to Patrick
thanks Jen it's really exciting to see a
new way for developers to easily extend
their services into cars with
conversational voice powered by the
Google assistant we hope to see many new
types of apps and use cases by next i/o
you also heard from AJ earlier on how
media and messaging apps can extend into
the car through a scalable way without
Android Auto templates and notification
extensions Android auto and the Google
assistant abstract most of the
complexity of automotive development so
that you can just worry about building a
great app and experience for your cars
or for your drivers this model has
helped Android auto grow to be the
largest in-car ecosystem today and it's
about to get a whole lot bigger with the
Google assistant with 10x growth and
users over the last year and new
partners like Audi and Volvo building
Android directly into their cars we know
that developers are going to have plenty
of eager drivers out there who want to
stay connected on the road so we're
excited to continue this road ahead with
all of you to build the future of
automotive infotainment and create a
safe and seamless experience for drivers
everywhere thanks and enjoy the rest of
the show
[Applause]
[Music]